students on the falcon force robotics
team at coral academy of science are
preparing for a championship competition
in dallas the first year team already
has a number of awards which helped them
qualify to compete in the vex iq world
championships in may it's where they'll
be facing over 700 teams from all across
the world this season's challenge is
focused on building a robot that will
shoot balls into a basket for certain
points
we're really really excited
we just started a few months ago so
we're kind of like babies compared to
the other teams
so
yeah this was really unexpected one of
our hardest challenges has been getting
our robot to not encounter any errors
throughout all the competitions
when we made our robot we decided to
completely start from scratch no
instructions at all and we used our own
basic ideas throughout our design
process and from there
we developed a robot that could
sufficiently accomplish our tasks we
have a mixture of kids that can do all
those different things whether it's
coding writing
and building but it's just exciting that
because of what they've been able to
shine and show
we get that opportunity to face those
800 t well 799 teams from around the
world
if you'd like to support the falcon
force robotics team we have a gofundme
link on our website 8newsnow.com